>> Tucker: NOW THE ISSUE OF
HORSE MEAT.
EATING HORSES HAS BEEN TABOO FOR
ALMOST ALL OF AMERICAN HISTORY
AND FOR GOOD REASON.
BUT RECENTLY CONGRESS HAS
THOUGHT TO CHANGE.
HERE IS WHAT DAVE HAD TO SAY
ABOUT IT?
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER FOR HAVING
ME ON.
>> Tucker: THIS AS YOU WELL
KNOW, STRIKES PEOPLE IN THE
CITIES AS HORRIFYING.
WHY IS IT A GOOD IDEA?
>> IT IS MAINLY A WELFARE ISSUE.
THE HORSE WORLD IS GONE DOWNHILL
EVERY SINCE WHEN YOU HAVE
SOMETHING THAT DOESN'T HAVE
VALUE WHICH IS WHAT THE UNWANTED
HORSE IS, THEY ARE SHIPPED TO
CANADA AND MEXICO AND THEY ARE
NOT WORTH ANYTHING.
>> Tucker: WE HAVE A LOT OF
PROBLEMS WITH DOMESTICATED
ANIMALS; CATS AND DOGS AND WE
DON'T EAT THEM.
IT CROSSES A LINE.
WHY ARE SO HORSES DIFFERENT?
>> HORSES IS CONSIDERED
LIVESTOCK IN EVERY STATE IN THE
UNION AND THEY ARE ON AVERAGE
A THOUSAND POUND ANIMAL.
YOU START ETHANIZING THE ONE
50,000 HORSES A YEAR, YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT MILLIONS OF POUNDS
OF TOXIC WASTE.
>> Tucker: IT IS A QUESTION OF
DISPOSING AND WHO WOULD EAT IT?
>> WELL, WE HAVE QUITE A MARKET
ACTUALLY.
IN 2011, WHEN THE RIDER'S CAME
OFF OF THE APPROPRIATION SAYS
BILL.
I WAS ADVOCATING FOR IT.
AND I WAS CONTACTED BY THE
TONGUN COMMUNITY AND A MEAT
BUYER IN THE SOUTH IN FLORIDA
WHO HAD 2.3 MILLION HISPANICS
WHO WOULD EAT IT EVERY DAY IF
THEY COULD GET IT.
MANY ETHNIC GROUPS.
>> Tucker: AMERICA IS DISTINCT
IN THAT WE DON'T EAT IT AND THE
FRENCH DO.
AND IT HAS BEEN A MORE THAN
CENTURY POINT OF PRIDE AND
BRAGGING OF LIKE YOU EAT HORSES
AND WE DON'T.
DOESN'T THIS PUT US AT THE LEVEL
OF THE FRENCH?
>> THAT IS A TOTAL MISNOMER.
OVER 50 PERCENT OF THE WORLD'S
COUNTRIES AND WE'LL FIND HORSE
MEAT INDUSTRY THAN ANY OTHER
TYPE OF MEAT.
AND CHINESE AND JAPANESE AND ALL
OF THE AFRICA, IF THEY CAN GET
AHOLD OF HORSE MEAT THEY WILL
EAT IT.
IF YOU ATE TACOS ON THE BEACH IN
KABO, YOU HAVE EATEN HORSE MEAT.
1985 HORSE MEAT WAS AVAILABLE ON
THE MENU AND THE HARVARD FACULTY
CLUB.
AND THE ONLY REASON THEY DIDN'T
KEECH IT.
THE NEW CHEF DIDN'T WANT TO COOK
ANYTHING THAT WAS FROZEN AND
THAT WAS IN 1985.
WE HAVE A HUGE HISTORY OF HORSE
MEAT CONSUMPTION IN THE UNITED
STATES.
AND THE HUMANE SOCIETY IN THE
UNITED STATES WILL TRY TO TELL
YOU THAT THAT IS NOT SO.
WELL, IT IS SO.
IT DOESN'T TAKE MUCH GOOINGLING
AND LOOKING AROUND TO FIND WE
DID CONSUME A LOT OF HORSE MEAT
IN THE UNITED STATES.